Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's and welcome to another edition of Conner's clinic live.
Today we are bringing a great guest from Canada. So up at Montreal, Canada, Nick, Nick Pino is,
I know him as an expert in EMF and the dangers of EMF. I subscribe to his newsletter.
Oh gosh, maybe it was a year or so ago, maybe it was longer than that ago.
And just the wealth of knowledge that you have and that you bring to the table regarding
the dangers of EMF to our health. And now it should even be a little bit more scary with 5G
rolling out. So I'm going to stop talking and I want to gain information from you and have
our listeners learn from you. So Nick, tell us more about you.
Sure. Well, I'm a citizen journalist. I'm from Montreal and I've been writing about health.
And mainly nutrition was my main topic of interest and how to pick the right foods in the grocery
stores and whatnot. When I started getting into health after university, I have a background
in communications and then I did advertising for a few years. So I've always been writing and
doing marketing. And this is this is where I guess I was able to self-publish my book online
and actually find audiences for it as part of the reason because I do have a marketing background.
So when I when I stumbled upon the topic of VMF in around 2015 and 2016,
I read several books that inspired me from scientists such as the late Dr. Martin Blank,
who was a professor at Columbia University. And he had a background in biology and physics.
And to him, the dangers of EMS were very, very crystal clear. And I discovered at that point that
there were around 240 to 300 scientists worldwide that are studying EMS with little funding.
And most of them are self-funded or are true philanthropy or non-profits because it's not a popular
topic and almost no one wants to look at it. And these scientists have tried to warn governments and
the UN and the WHO that actions need to be taken in the sense that we need to start reducing
our exposure to these fields. And I'm talking about the EMS, the electromagnetic fields emitted by
cell phones, Wi-Fi and Bluetooth that are so ubiquitous these days. So that's that was really my story
was discovering the topic and then trying to make sense of it for for me, my friends, my immediate
family. And then writing my findings in a book, which I published in 2017, which tell us a little
bit about your book. We had a pushy book here. Yeah, the non-tin foil guide to EMS it's called. And
that's kind of a cheeky title. So people who don't know what what this is referring to. A lot of
even even the Justin Trudeau are incredible premiere talked about tin foil hadders very recently in
his speech, talking about conspiracy theorists. And in other words, it's a deprecating way of talking
about people who believe that EMS is a problem because they were in certain depictions like in that
movie, signs with joke and phoenix people were tin foil hats to protect themselves from extraterrestrial
send signals or something like that. So I wanted to have that in the title because there's some
and I must say a lot of information on the internet that is hyperbolic incorrect kind of fear mongering
around EMS. And I think it is it is creating a lot of troubles for scientists that are studying the
topic and publishing very legit and credible information. It's kind of mudding the waters if you will.
So unfortunately, there's a lot of craziness that is said about EMS. The reality as I put it in my book
is that this is an environmental toxin and we need to consider it the same as the toxins we find in
our foods such as pesticides or glyphosate and whatnot or the toxins in water. And we saw that many
people who listen to this or who are interested in how these days after hearing about the amount of
glyphosate that is found in in everyday foods or after hearing about different different municipal
waters that were tainted with different heavy metals or copper and whatnot. They realize that
we need to minimize our exposure to these environmental toxins. The topic of EMS is the same.
The difference is that for some people it's a little bit harder to grasp because these are invisible
signals and it's not like you're putting something in your body such as drinking or eating something
but those signals are around us. And when they are closest to our body, this is where they create the
most stress. So it is an environmental stressor that is that we must not overlook.
Well, and I really like what you said about we don't want to be fear mongers and pay to picture
that is too far on one side that EMS are going to kill everybody and because we know from a
genetic standpoint that just from a clinical standpoint that different people are affected different
ways. Can you talk a little bit about that? Sure, there are there are many lines of evidence that
show that certain people have a genetic background. It could be genetic could be something else but
they just react in a very, very important way when they are faced with EMS and they will these
individuals, some researchers would call them electro hyper sensitives. Some would say that's
microwave illness in the sense that oh, it's not a sensitivity because everyone is impacted.
There are different terms for it. Environmental acquired illness is also a category of disease where
depending on which attorney or doctor you talk to, they will have different terms for it but you could
have in a couple and this this happens oftentimes women seems to be more sensitive. So in a given
couple, they might be in their home using the phone, the Wi-Fi, the Bluetooth earpiece, anything
like that and the man usually doesn't have a sensitivity or it's a little bit more rare and the women
have an extreme sensitivity in many situations. So for example, one of the two partners might be
able to get sleep, deep sleep, no problem with a phone under the pillow or near their bed stand
whereas the sensitive person, so-called sensitive, might have problems with sleep and when they
turn off the sensitive individual, turn off the cell phone, they see a dramatic reduction in
our improvement in their sleep, a reduction in how much it impacts their sleep quality. So it's really
individual and it does not necessarily correlate with the state of health and that's a tricky part.
Some people with chronic disease or who already have many environmentally acquired sensitivity,
such as chemical sensitivity, are normally or in many situations also EMF sensitive. So in those
individuals, it's more like of an acquired sensitivity to EMFs but the fact remains that I still see
individuals that are that have perfect labs, very healthy lifestyles and they are just sensitive
the fact though, they seem to have some researchers think this has to do with certain
certain SNAP, certain epigenetics which is being impacted such as the calcium
uptake in certain certain genes that are related to calcium uptake or to nitric oxide production but
there's no really we don't have a definitive answer about what makes one person sensitive and the
next not sensitive. Yeah, I would agree with you wholeheartedly there. You know we get comments from
our patients like how do we get rid of all the EMFs? How do we make our house EMF free and I try to
tell people you can't. So the idea is you try to reduce exposure just like how do you get rid of all
the toxins in your environment so you're not gonna swallow any pesticides you can't even if you eat
perfect and all organic and you'd ever go out to eat, you're still gonna be exposed to pesticides
and herbicides. EMFs are going through us right now that's why we can you know put up a radio
turn it on and we can get you know 40 different stations because radio waves are going through us
right now. So it's impossible to live in a bubble where you're not gonna be exposed to these things.
So what are what are some general things that you recommend to you know you're still we still
all have to have cell phones we still all have computers we're out of computer right now.
What are some things that you can do to reduce exposure? Sure, well the number one room that should
be mitigated against the EMFs where you should really pay attention is your bedroom and this is
because most of the harms of the EMFs seems to be by depriving you of the best sleep you can get
itself an impact on your repair mechanism on your ability to detoxify on your ability to keep
your blood sugar stable and things like that. So it's very very important to reduce EMF exposure
when you're trying to get shut eye and one of their mechanisms could be that EMFs is something
that's keeping you excited. That is something that is preventing your nervous system from going in
that rest mode and that that parasympathetic mode. And this is often seen in people that are more
sensitive. I remember that I used to be more sensitive when my state of health wasn't as good.
And when a wife or outer was open near me and an apartment rented in Montreal back in 2017 with my
wife when the wife or outer was on at night mistakenly because usually we turned it off but when it was
on I woke up sometimes at 3 a.m. with my heart beating so fast. So a type of adrenaline rush
a stress reaction and that's oftentimes what people describe either that or they cannot they're
insomniac they cannot calm down and finally go to sleep so they toss and turn. So this is really why
you want to turn off the cell phone in your room or set it as far away as possible from your pillow
right so create that distance from these machines turn off the laptop turn off if you have Bluetooth
alarm clocks or cordless phones any of these wireless machines you do not want to set them very close
to the pillow as far away as possible or in another room so it depends on what setup you have but
generally speaking nothing under the pillow nothing on the bed stand on that table there should not be
wireless devices there so if you only follow that a lot of people report improvements in their
sleep quality so this is really number one and I would argue number two is the room where you spend
most of your days and for many people for me as an entrepreneur these days I work at home a lot so it
would be the same room as my bedroom that's also my office but it would be that computer so what do
you do with that computer whether you're at the office in an outside environment or at home and what
you can do and what you should do is opt for wired technologies rather than wireless and this is
still feasible you can hire an IT company and they can have a wire run from your router to your computer
and that's a Ethernet cable and many people tell me that they're surprised to hear that the wired
technologies even exist nowadays because we're all about Wi-Fi but it is more stable it is
faster than Wi-Fi much more reliable it's unhackable also on an internet security standpoint or much
harder to hack and then it's something that is a semi permanent solution where if you're in an office
environment and you do not plan to move your laptop around and work on the sofa and here and there
which is my case and the case of most entrepreneurs I talk to these days well why would you be on Wi-Fi
there's really no benefit to be on Wi-Fi it's just something that people do but if you can avoid it
it's gonna be it's gonna represent a big chunk of your overall cumulative exposure to EMS that's
gonna go down which is why you want to focus on it if you work on a computer like me about 40 hours
per week yeah that's great advice yeah we tell people to turn their Wi-Fi I just put it on a little
toggle switch where you can flip it off every night and you're not using it turn it off it's
more difficult if you're in an apartment where you're you know you're at three neighbors you know
that are close vicinity of you they all have their Wi-Fi on you're really bombarded with Wi-Fi
maybe have a talk with them and maybe try to communicate with them and share the benefits health
benefits of reducing that you know at least at certain times of the day that's very true and the
fact remains depending on your setup your Wi-Fi router might be the one that is closest to your body
and that's often the case even if it's not the case turn it off it's it's not as much the power
levels that is harmful as the sheer amount of different devices that we have in our vicinity the
more different devices you have the more chaos that is being sent through your body so just as an
overall principle if you turn off your devices at home you're doing good if you try to minimize how
exposed you are by your cell phone and you decide to take calls on a corded landline or you decide
to take calls on your computer on a true skype or zoom instead of a cell phone on your face while
you're reducing exposure and you're doing good so again when it comes to email there's a lot of
exposures we cannot initially turn off I cannot at the moment I cannot tell my neighbor okay turn
off your router I might convince my neighbor which would be good but again I cannot go outside
Montreal and see a South Tower and say oh I'm gonna turn that off tonight to sleep better
doesn't work that way at the moment so you can initially shield yourself against all the outside
exposures although there are more advanced strategies that do exist to create a shielded room for
example and some doctors and functional medicine that I've been interviewing in the last years are
doing that for some patients especially the electro sensitive ones that live in a city environment or
in a highly electro polluted environment in the in those cases this is equivalent to doing a mold
remediation that is more advanced for these patients if they do not shield the bedroom or
dramatically reduce exposure sometimes they're unable to cope with that exposure and they just keep
getting worse right that we've had people use grounding sheets grounding pillows we've had people
put a grounding sheet over the top so they're enveloped in a ground if they're in an environment where
the the bedroom is adjacent to a wall of somebody you know another person like in an apartment or
condo they may hang your grounding sheet on the wall doesn't look very pretty but it's better of your
health it's important um so there are other and more advanced things but you brought up the big
point of that this these aren't cumulative so the the more that you can do to reduce the better
you're going to be it's not about getting down to ground zero it's not really even possible
in most environments but you're just trying to reduce that exposure that's going to be the best thing
for health completely correct and I tried to show every day example of what I do when I travel for
example on my youtube channel and sometimes it's as simple as entering a hotel room that's a good
example because that's a new environment that you don't know you don't know what emits EMS in
that room and you want to get restorative sleep maybe you're in between two flights or sometimes I'm
giving a conference in the US so I want to get a good night at sleep and rest and repair but I just
look in the environment near the bed stand and sometimes there's a cordless phone sometimes there's
the Bluetooth alarm clock and I don't need these if I need to call the front desk I will plug the
phone back in and dial zero and that's fine but during the night it keeps emitting at very very
strong intensities which is downright silly because the rest of the room is set up as these comfy pillows
and the room is so comfortable but a lot of people report to me that they don't feel well in hotel
rooms and part of it is might be the chemicals they use for cleaning or whatnot but also the EMS are
quite high in most rooms that I've measured so it's just a matter of of knowing these things and
you don't see it but you can have an extra set of eyes through the use of an EMF detector for example
so you could go through the room and look at different machines and does this smart tv emit a signal
if so I can unplug it and and then you get a better night of sleep and you just try to minimize the
levels in that room and again elimination is certainly not possible but if you can only do that
over time over time you reduce your exposure and the scientific studies have confirmed that the bulk
of our exposure still is coming from the wife or router from the cordless phone from the cell phones
and from the different machines plugged in Wi-Fi such as a laptop or a desk like computer so it's
still true that the bulk of our exposure comes from these things of course we have outside
exposures that we can think about but yeah for more sensitive patients it makes more sense to think
about the outside environment for someone not sensitive just trying to do preventative measures
I think it's very it's very important to let everyone know that you can control these things and
that it does make a difference when you do so a lot of people are concerned about 5G
yes so we need to touch on that what's the you know the truth about 5G well a lot of it is unknown
because it's just starting but give us your take on how we can protect ourselves what is the
dangers of it et cetera yeah correct you know the biggest study about carcinogenicity of these
EMFs came out in 2018 and that was the NTP study the national toxicology program it studied 2G
and 3G technologies and that's a project that started at the end of the 90s and it took pretty much
20 years to organize but together do the study do the peer review and their conclusion was that okay this
is a clear carcinogen in rats and mice in a few cancer or tumor types so it tells you that okay the
dangers are there but it also tells you something that is you get to read between the lines this was
2G and 3G technology that was being used in that study that just ended four years ago as we're
recording this so that's kind of crazy to me that well these technologies are are already
deprecated most people do not use 2G and 3G they are on 4G LTE or 5G now on their phones so our
ability to study the dangers is greatly surpassed by the speed at which we have new technologies coming
out so and why I'm giving this background is that why is 5G considered danger as the facto by
scientists well all the previous technologies were unsafe and we are at the moment still
uncovering the dangers of previous technologies so there's no reason to think to quote Joel
Moskowitz PhD who's been in policy and really really talking about EMFs and trying to make change
because he said in a in a scientific American article he said we have no reason to think
that 5G is safe there's zero reason it would be say considering that all previous versions were
already harmful to some degree and we know that there's effects on fertility cancer risks and
there's many different lines of evidence that confirm it so when we have 5G new signals that are
being used sometimes in the very high millimeter waves we have more towers closer to people more
intensity and we also have scientific confirmation now from one study that is very recent that when 5G
is installed in a city the electro pollution background levels will raise a chord 40 entire
population so the unavoidable exposures go up because again you're just adding so many towers that
you're adding more to the problem and really the problem with 5G to me is not that 5G is that
different from previous technologies or inherently more dangerous which is what a lot of people online
have tried to depict oh 5G is so dangerous compared to other technologies and I don't agree with that
personally I see that all previous technologies were unsafe and 5G is equally unsafe and potentially
even more unsafe because we go in more and more complex signal characteristics which means that
for the same unit of measurement in the amount of radiation you're measuring on an EMF meter you might
have double the harmful effects and that's still in theory but this is what we've seen from 3G to 4G
where you have the same amount of power level but even more biological effect so the more we temper
with the signals and make the signals modify the signal with electrical engineering in a way that
make them better able to connect to the tower and able to send more packets and two ways and there's
all sorts of tempering that they do with the signal these things have one focus in mind connectivity
and it's not biological compatibility right so this is not taken into the equation at all so
this is really why scientists are calling for a worldwide moratorium on the installation of new
towers or new technology but there's a huge incentive for the industry and even governments to keep
going with new technologies because there's also other aspects in society that would be upgraded by
the 5G networks and beyond or at least that's the rhetoric at the moment the reality is many people
in technologies say you know we don't need 5G to do autonomous cars we could use infrared or we could
use light signals we could use other things rather than 5G millimeter ways it's just that what the
industry is selling is okay 5G will lead us in the future and if we don't have 5G we don't have the
future that's a cool story but it looks more of a marketing message rather than really an engineer
analysis of where we want to go with technology or where where we should go to better society so it's
something where we could rely still on a lot of fiber optics and wired technology and then minimize the
amount that our wireless technologies are emitting rather than increasing the amount that we're
exposing ourselves given the dangers so bottom line is the more things that you could do as a it would
be to protect yourself the wiser it is going to be ultimately we just don't know the effects of
EMFs as a whole because the studies are so far behind how fast technology is advancing so just anything
you could do to protect yourself I know that on a lot of the new folds you could actually turn off your
5G capability so a lot of people are doing that that's something to search for on your browser and
figure out how to turn off your 5G capability I would do that then in the phone in cellar setting
sometimes you can decide you can force your phone to connect to the 4G network for example rather
than 5G is it a good idea yes but again do not be fooled into thinking that 4G is safe
3G was not safe right so so it means that the same precautions need to be taken for example if you
put a phone in your pocket all day every day it should be on airplane mode or are do not keep it in
your pocket if you're moving around the city understand but still try to turn it off or have a
special case there are certain specialized products that deflect the radiation off of your body when
you're carrying it in the pocket but the Cleveland Clinic researchers even in 2010 12 years ago were
warning men that the top 5 reasons that fertility is reduced in men is cell phone radiation but that
scientific understanding does not make it in policy at the moment there's barely any progress
towards selling users do not put a phone in your pocket although when it comes to researchers and
fertility there's no doubt in their mind that it is impairing sperm count or quality so that's
crazy to me that we know scientifically there's damage and yet the average person on the street would
not know it at all right nothing is being done about it it's not changing policy well because you
are a wealth of knowledge tell people how they can find you and get on your newsletter list
sounds good so at the emfguy.com and there's a I have a special report on 5G that goes into a
little bit more detail than what we talked about today and if people subscribe to that they're
going to get on my newsletter right after I also have a podcast where I explore questions of
the safe and unsafe technologies including healing therapeutic technologies such as red light therapy
or even pemf the pulse electromagnetic field therapy and various frequencies we can use to
heal because there's also the good side of technological developments best for sure yeah well thank you so
much we'll have your information up on our podcast site I'd love to have you back I know our listeners
are just excited to hear your your knowledge and I do agree I think there's a lot of misinformation
out there about emf's that scares people on one side and and certainly all the cell phone companies
are put out complete mail information of pemf's honey emf's so we the more we could get this out
the better so thank you for being on I appreciate you and I'd love to have you back in the next
couple months it sounds good it would be my pleasure thank you all right all right thanks again bye bye